I know that this road has been very hard
and yet here you are building This
Magnificent family
what's going on in that head of yours
something a little piece of it he said
Dad
they're not afraid of anything
but I am
afraid of losing someone I love
Dominic Toretto you're about to learn
all about fear boom
such a beautiful life filled with love
and family I never got that chance
you stole that from me
my future
my family
and now
I'm gonna break yours
by peace
[Music]
[Applause]
he's coming for you with everything
what's the plan Dom I'm not sure anymore
one of us might not come back from this
but we have to fight
never accept death
suffering is old
[Music]
set up he's trying to tear us apart
winning used to be about winning we
raced for respect
today I race to stop the blood back
that's the problem with having such a
big family
how do you choose the ones you save
Let's Race
foreign
[Music]
best time
here they come you will never be able to
break my family
[Music]
good morning sunshine you gotta be
kidding me
[Music]